a pesar de los enfrentamientos abiertos
sobre Ucrania la casa blanca y el
kremlin están en comunicación el asesor
de seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
Jake Sullivan confirmó el lunes que ha
estado en contacto con altos asesores de
Vladimir Putin durante varios meses las
conversaciones privadas se centraron
principalmente en limitar la escalada de
la guerra en Ucrania y evitar el uso de
armas nucleares nosotros en la
administración de biden hemos tenido la
oportunidad de comprometernos altos
niveles con los rusos para comunicarnos
para reducir el riesgo para transmitir
la consecuencia del uso potencial de las
armas nucleares putina insinuado en
repetidas ocasiones que podría recurrir
a la fuerza nuclear si las cosas no
salen como él quiere en Ucrania
provocando la condena internacional y
una feroz reprimenda por parte de los
funcionarios estadounidenses no está
claro si el presidente ruso ha
participado directamente en las
recientes conversaciones con Washington
el kremlin de entrada ha negado
rotundamente las negociaciones
no tenemos nada que decir sobre esta
publicación los periódicos anglosajones
publican muchas falsedades
durante la Guerra Fría la casa blanca y
el kremlin mantuvieron un canal de
comunicación directa conocido como
hotline para ayudar a reducir la
posibilidad de la guerra nuclear